at the height of the Second World War
the Allied forces were planning a secret
mission to invade Nazi occupied Sicily
in order to confuse the Germans they
devised an audacious and utterly bizarre
plan a plan which hinged on the ultimate
success of one man a man who was already
dead on April 30th 1943 a Spanish
fisherman discovered the body of a
British soldier off the coast of Spain
the dead soldier had a briefcase
handcuffed to his wrist
the Nazis got a hold of the body and
examined the man in his possessions what
they uncovered astounded them the dead
soldier carried letters which described
critical details of the Allies plan to
invade Greece Nazi officials including
Hitler himself were convinced they had
stumbled upon the greatest military
intercept of the Second World War the
only issue for the Nazis was the dead
soldier in all of the details outlining
the pending invasion were a fantastical
ruse designed to foil the German army
the idea was conceived by a group within
British intelligence which included Ian
Fleming yep the guy who wrote James Bond
to pull it off the team had procured the
body of a 34 year old man who had died
the month before they gave the guy a
uniform a fake passport theater tickets
a picture of a girlfriend and even loose
tobacco to make him appear real they
drove from London to Scotland and they
put it on a submarine two days later the
body was placed in the ocean where it
was later found
Hitler was so convinced that he moved
the bulk of his forces to Greece in
preparation for the pending invasion an
invasion that never came so when the
Allies landed in Sicily they encountered
a whole lot less resistance occupied
southern Italy and ultimately changed
the course of the war thanks to one dead
man and a crazy plan
you